Megan hello it is so good to see you
I'm trying to contain my excitement you
know I'm very honored to speak with you
after Meg the stallion
[Music]
likewise Taylor admiration how surprised
were you after that video I mean did you
know that she was going to be the person
announcing you walk me through the
moment that you saw it all no I I did
not know that the Megan was uh gonna be
introducing introducing me
I was immediately I was like I had the
best one on the team uh I mean Crystal
had Crystal had little Wayne that was
pretty good but like next Italian come
on
yeah and I mean just the Megan
connection it was so perfect love that
moment for you all I watched that whole
thing and it was just really nice to see
you all get all of the love that you
deserve and I mean for you it is your
fourth Women's World Cup appearance I
want to talk a bit about how your role
has changed every year that you've done
the Women's World Cup and also just
where you're at in life has changed
every year that you've done it so
starting with year one and then go
through them can you put a title to the
role that you had in those years oh man
um the my first World Cup was a little
tough to be honest
um it I was basically a starter like all
the way uh leading up to the World Cup
and without that much conversation uh
Pia at the time uh I got benched like
literally like two and three days before
I mean I've always been much more of a
gamer than uh you know practice like
what are we talking about I've learned
to practice a lot better and understand
the importance and the value and
practice you can't actually play the
games unless you practice well
um but that one was tough because I felt
like
um I should have been a starter I feel
like I should have been
um playing but I just took the
opportunities that I had and you know a
little like kind of personal victory in
that World Cup was uh you know working
when I'm working my way back and you
know when the final came about uh you
know I was in the starting 11 and on the
field and impactful in that way
um I mean I think for for me it's like
was kind of my introduction to the world
in terms of like this is this is who I
am this is kind of like what what kind
of player I am I love the big moments
um you know of course there's pressure
and of course you're nervous I'm you
know I'm not like a cyborg or anything
but I love it I think it's so much fun
it's like you don't do all this work and
sacrifice and uh you know all the BS you
have to do to be an elite athlete
um like that's the payoff is is getting
to play in front of these stadiums and
getting to play in front of these fans
and be in those moments obviously I had
the crazy game against Brazil it's still
like I just like it's just ridiculous
that that whole game and
um the cross the Abbey and everything
um so that was like yeah I guess allow
me to to uh introduce myself to the
world
um
second one honestly it felt like a home
World Cup you know with it being in
Canada But but so close to the US
stadiums are red white and blue
everywhere we went
um you know that one was was tough I
didn't feel like we always played that
well but it was just like you know
quintessential U.S finding a way to win
all of those games
um you know definitely in 2019 that was
like the you know a crowning moment of
my career I feel like
everything kind of came to together like
my personality everything that we were
fighting for off of the field you know
coming through you know 2016 and 17
where I feel like uh I was you know if I
would have went away they would have
been like awesome that
uh go ahead and keep going away
um so having to like fight through that
moment yeah they were like cool girl uh
feel free to not come back
um but obviously like you know what it
meant to be you know fighting for equal
pay and what it meant to kneel with cap
and you know come alongside the WNBA
players and you know being a part of
definitely in the US but I feel like in
a world that was just dramatically
changing very quickly
um you know dyeing my hair pink like it
oh I feel like that was like a real
culmination of like this is this is who
I am this is all the things yeah
um that I want to embody the embodiment
of Joy but also the embodiment of of
fighting for things off the field and
expressing who I am and being able to be
a a much sort of like Fuller person in
that way and you know the tournament was
incredible
um you know crazy games and obviously
having you know president tweeting I
like hate tweeting at us but also I was
like you seem kind of into it so I'm not
really sure what's happening but you're
watching
yeah oh my God it seems like you're
tuned in sir
um so that was you know just I think
that's just like one of gonna be like
one of the most incredible moments of my
entire life like you can't write that
script any better uh you know being able
to score in the World Cup final and
um having the whole stadium chant equal
pay and and doing it like with like my
group of players like that was like our
generation like some of my best friends
uh were on that team so that was really
special obviously now you know I'm on
the the Megan rapino End of the Age gap
which apparently starts at Alyssa and
ends up me uh as Alex said
um it's a it's a way different yeah it's
a way different
um experience I mean obviously you sort
of said you've talked about my role
changing a lot I've talked about that a
lot it's going to look way different I
won't
um you know probably be on the field as
much as I was in in past times but I'm
still feeling I can have a lot of impact
and this one I feel like is just going
to be really special everything we've
been fighting for for the last you know
really like eight years the past two
World Cups have been so focused uh
particularly 2019 so focused on
that like breaking through the wall or
breaking through the ceiling and like
really like grabbing hold of that
progress I feel like we've done that now
and now it's like okay and this is what
we can do like this is what we've been
saying all along this is like an
opportunity I think for everyone to see
us not not an opportunity for us to show
opportunity for everybody who's been
late to the party to come and watch
what's been amazing the whole time
absolutely and so with that being said
is it fair to say that maybe you feel
lighter This World Cup just because of
what it allows you to focus on in this
moment
I think in ways yeah in ways I feel
lighter ways it feels more like okay we
can just like go out and play and enjoy
ourselves
um and really just like enjoy what an
incredible tournament this would be it's
like I already know all the all the
Women's World Cups are better than the
last one
um and I don't think this would be any
different but even just like the ticket
sales coming in uh more prize money like
where it'll be I think as well Australia
New Zealand or like you know rival
America for like insanity when it comes
to sporting culture so I think like that
level of intensity and just like
interest uh will really be there
um but then sometimes I'm like dang I'm
old I know a lot like I'm like thinking
about all the things that I know and
like are we doing this or doing this are
we doing this so sometimes I'm just like
okay you don't need to think about
everything you can control everything
like I'll try to prepare myself and the
team you know as much as possible but
like ultimately you've got to go out and
kick the ball and uh you know do what
you do on the field and I think you know
looking back at my password cups like
the best thing is to just be on burden
and to just play like we have so much
talent on the team we have so many new
players we have so much personality and
like spice out there on the field that
it's just like let everybody chill and
go do their thing and really just like
enjoy every moment for what it is
because it's incredibly special
yeah you know I love hearing you talk
about the past World Cups and just where
you were at in those moments in time
because the World Cups kind of have
served as markers on your journey both
for you personally but also everybody
that is observing you because at this
point you have just seen so much and I
was listening to a podcast that you did
with some teammates and in it they
called you their wisest most trusted
teammate and your response to them was
well yeah it's because I've made so many
mistakes
so what mistake that you have made in
your career did you learn the most from
you always come with a hard hit or
sailor oh gosh I mean what mistakes I've
I feel like I made all every mistake I
mean just like in in general
um I think
I mean it's tough It's I've been through
like so many relationships with coaches
obviously uh you know I wrote about that
in my book Jill and I had a little bit
of a strained relationship so I think
some of the you know some of the ways
that I handled that or just feeling like
things are so stressful in the moment
which I think sometimes you just can
take a step back and
um
not have to like worry so much things
will sort of figure figure itself out
we're not like doing rocket science here
we're just going out and playing a game
that we that we all love so much
um one mistake I keep repeating is
packing way too much I have so much
stuff and I'm I'm not gonna need it all
but that's fine
um but I think just I don't know if I've
made this mistake but I feel like what I
want to tell the younger players like
really really enjoy every moment
celebrate these moments you don't get to
go back and celebrate you don't get to
go back and enjoy these moments like
whether it's making the World Cup team
for the first time and just like
celebrating that and being happy let
yourself like feel that Joy or scoring
your first goal in a world cup or
scoring a goal in a world cup is special
winning different games making it to
different stages like I think that's
something that this team has always done
a really good job of but I know for
myself that's been important to me like
you can take the moment it doesn't mean
you're not focused like not not sort of
onboarding those whack narratives from
you know people who've never been in
that position like you need to celebrate
and enjoy every single moment like it it
gets hard at times and I feel like being
able to balance that with the joy and
when the with the excitement and
um just with kind of like feeling what
you're feeling is is really important to
being successful in the end like you
can't just be focused for you know 40
days straight we're gonna be on this
trip forever more than 40 days we're
only tripping like two months but the
World Cup is you know just over a month
long and like you can't just stay
focused the whole time like I've been in
this a long time that's like
that does it doesn't work like that like
Elite athletes don't operate like that
as much as you know some people want to
say that say that they do I'm like you
need that balance and you need to let
loose and you lay your hair out and you
need to relax a little bit and just
enjoy every moment
yeah you gotta have the moments where
you can kind of just be alone deep pre
debriefed you're already
compartmentalizing so much as an athlete
you have to have those those times you
step away and just being present um and
feeling present
um for this world cup your coach said
Megan is going to have different type of
minutes what do you hear when you hear
that I mean I've been used to being a
you know being a starter you know one of
the kind of obvious names on on the team
Sheet every every game and that's going
to look really different
um I think in general our our uh you
know game to game roster could be very
different like and it's just looking
back 2019 all of us have played together
for so long it's pretty like really 2017
18 and 19 it was like this is this is
the team this is rotations all that it
was it was much more clear I think we're
gonna have to be really Nimble I think
we're gonna have to really be like
finger on the pulse during the games of
what's Happening like if we're up to nil
like I'm not going into the game you
know like I'm not gonna be playing in
those games but if we're tied or we're
down or we need a different kind of
spark
um that's what it's going to look like
so I think it's I don't really know and
and to be honest I don't think black hoe
really knows and I think we're we're
cool with that like for me
whatever impact I can have whenever I'm
called upon and I think you know being
able to draw from my experience like I'm
going to want to play all the time
everybody wants to play all the time
obviously it's not that I I don't want
to play all the minutes but you know I'm
I'm confident and you know we have such
a great relationship and such like open
communication like if I get used it's
because it's I'm the best person to be
used in that moment if I don't get used
then like my impact will be be the same
um I think that's you know something
that's really unique about this
tournament is that regardless of whether
you're playing or not like you're so
important to the sort of overall like
Vibe and emotional mental physical like
health of the team like it's really
important that those players like keep
everyone together because it is hard and
it doesn't go individually the way that
everyone would like 11 players start and
we get five Subs not everybody's gonna
play not everybody's going to play every
minute not everybody's going to score
every goal so you know people have
different roles and I feel like
to be honest I feel like if I can accept
my role I don't hear nothing about
anybody else except in any kind of role
so I feel like it's a yeah it's a good
example and like really yeah like really
understanding that it takes is cliche
but it really takes everyone like diving
into their role a hundred percent and I
just like guarantee you if we win at the
end like it's all worth it
absolutely you know I'm I'm that's
really interesting that you said that
when you were like you know if I have
accepted my role I feel like everybody
can because I agree and when you really
step back and think about the role that
that acceptance part of it has it been
hard has it been easy you know whenever
I think about athletes who obviously
have had such great and storied careers
when that moment comes where it shifts a
little bit always wonder how big of a
hurdle it is to switch your mind to that
switch as well
[Music]
I I think the the tougher part about it
for me was like just coming to terms
with like I can't do everything
physically that I used to or that I
might want to you know I feel like
obviously the mental part I just keep
getting better up here and sometimes
when the mental and physical doesn't
doesn't always translate perfectly with
each other that is more the frustrating
part I think as this type of elite
athlete having national team and you
know our league in the nwsl be such a
huge part of what we do it's not like
the World Cups every four years and we
get together a few weeks before and
that's kind of the only thing we're
together a lot and so to be able to have
my NWA style experience where I'm still
playing a lot and can still like
contribute you know so much and be
starting and playing a lot of the games
uh you know that kind of makes it easier
on the national team where I'm not doing
that or I'm not you know playing all of
the minutes but I feel like for me also
like I I'm just realistic in that like I
can't do that I'm not gonna be able to
play 9 minutes for seven games in a row
or six games in a row or even five games
so like I think I can still be really
impactful especially as an offensive
player uh you know we make those subs
late in the games are coming for 30
minutes or 15 minutes or be able to take
a half whatever it is
um I think I'm just like realistic and
like hey I can still contribute a lot
um you know maybe not as much as uh I'm
used to or as much as I used to before
but also I don't really need to because
we have all of these players that are
incredible and you know to bring a
player Off the Bench that has a kind of
experience and that has uh you know the
type of game that I have is really
unique oftentimes you bring in you know
players on the bench that are that are
younger or that don't have as much
experience so I feel like it's a it's a
unique balance at an offensive position
obviously vacuo has put you know a ton
of trust in me to to even you know bring
me or have me a part of the group and
just understanding this kind of unique
position that I can have so it's not you
know the easiest thing I think just
getting older and you know it takes
twice as long to do the same thing for
your body it takes twice as much work to
do the same do the same thing all the
time we talk about Susan all the time
shout out to Susan born short and
athlete I mean just you know they're
just incredible and working with us as
as our bodies change and as the
limitations and things arise but
um you know I feel like I can still be
really impactful and still get out there
and do what I do
yeah no you absolutely can I I
appreciate your your honesty there um
with how it has gone for you um just two
more questions for you I know that we
are a bit short on time as I was
prepping for this obviously I would see
your 2019 photo so much it is so iconic
so I thought okay I want you to give me
your top most iconic Sports photos
including yours so give me three more
that really stick out for you
oh my gosh
oh my goodness this one's tight I know
it's hard there's so many um yeah I mean
I think Michael Jordan in Utah after a
massive push-off on Bayern Scott who was
that
Brian something I can't remember that's
an iconic one with the hand up
um
Steph Curry's got like 20 of them I mean
the ring
um you know all the shimmies
um
Sue top of the key against
um Phoenix in 2018
iconic there's got to be one of Stewie
just like doing that
um Asia at the press conference with the
with the goggles with the goggles on the
side yeah
[Laughter]
yeah that that's iconic
um yeah and then yeah I'll put mine in
there I think on a on a world stage to
have a have a signature iconic
celebration in in in sort of the context
of everything that was going on I'll put
that one in there too there's gonna be
some I'm missing something with yourself
but no no yours it's like it's the story
it's all of it together and like what
that moment really signify that makes it
special so I agree with that list I'm
all in um last question for you
I was watching a lot of interviews that
you've done reading a lot of articles
that you had been a part of and you talk
about your team a lot as you should it's
very clear you love your teammates you
are a team first kind of player so I
just wanted to give you the moment to
talk about you because I want to know
what you want to mean to the sport and
what you feel like you have meant to the
sport up to this point I mean that's
tough I don't I don't think I get to
decide what what I mean to the sport
um
I feel like I know what the sport has
allowed me to do and the vehicle that
it's been
um you know and I and I feel like I
always have to say we in this because
being on this team and having this
platform
um you know and and of course I mean I
always say I made made the choice to
sort of Leverage America against itself
because there's like nothing that
America loves more a than America
America loves America more than anything
America loves sports and America loves
winners and America loves like Brash
arrogant people and so it's like it's
all here and to do it in my way and to
really have
the ability to leverage it for good
um I mean I think that's what what I'm
most proud of and most thankful for in
terms of what the sport has you know
allowed me to do
um you know it's it's also just given me
so much opportunity to do what I feel
like is really my life's purpose I feel
like I'm this
messenger type person so much of what I
say is not just what what I made up or
what I'm saying I'm speaking with people
I'm speaking on behalf of people using
this amazing platform to to do that and
continue to push for change whether it's
black lives matter or trans rights and
sports or lgbtq rights or equal pay
whatever it may be I feel like that's
the privilege that I have there's so
many amazing things that come with being
an elite athlete and being on this level
and being as successful as I've been and
being as successful as this team has
been I feel like that's the Natural
Balance I feel like you know the natural
order of things would be out of balance
if I just took took took and and didn't
give everything back and I think being
able to see in real time along with so
many other people that are fighting for
the same things whether it's you know
the WNBA or other soccer federations
fighting for you know equal treatment or
the way the MBA has used its platform or
different athletes like I think it's
really amazing to be a part of this I
know that it
culminates in certain people at certain
times and certain personalities have a
microphone and you know I've certainly
never shied away from the intention I
have freaking blue hair and I have pink
hair so it's like no one's up here
trying to be like oh I just went about
the business humbly I'm not that humble
yeah I have humility but I'm not that
humble
um but I do really feel a part of
something so much greater than myself
and so it's it's been an honor and a
privilege to be one of the mouthpieces
and to be one of
um you know the people that things have
culminated in I think I just always hope
that I've you know done it justice and
treated it all with respect and
um you know left the game in a better
place than where you found it I think
that's always really the goal and
um I don't I don't think it's
um sort of ostentatious to say that
we've left in in a much better place
than where we found it I think that's
the the most important thing to me and
the thing that I'm most proud of in my
career
what a beautiful answer I love that I
mean I know that you know this but you
are so many things to so many people
everyone is just thankful for your
existence I mean it's obviously already
incredibly easy to root for the USA that
you make it just even easier because I
love seeing you do well you know you're
my girl and thank you so much for your
time I'm sad I won't be making the trip
I'm gonna have major fomo with everybody
out there but I will be rooting here
from New York city so thank you so much
I'm still holding out you always pop up
I might see you down there